the first uh breaking point in my career
was uh
when uh the air force decided that i'm
not good enough to be a
a fighter pilot i would become a cargo
pilot
and that killed me um and i think that
was a very
important moment in my life
thank you for joining me today how are
you i'm very good
very good how are you i'm i'm doing
fantastic i think that
what you have is what people usually put
as a virtual background where are you
right now
i am in my back garden it's my uh
uh corona kingdom
wow it's a beautiful morning it's a it's
a beautiful garden thank you for joining
me
early in the day i really appreciate it
there's you know there's infinite things
really we can talk about and what i'd
really love to concentrate on these 20
minutes is understanding your personal
journey
going from being a major in the air
force as a pilot
to going and being an entrepreneur and
being the city and co-founder of v
to now we're being in viola group and
sitting on the board member of some of
the most
amazing companies they're one of my
favorite companies in the world immunize
norman norm and louis are incredible and
and i just love to understand your
journey a little bit better and your
personal insights
into investing in startups with
leveraging deep technology
and that's the field that i'm most
excited about and i can't wait to pick
your brain
so today guys start off tell me a little
bit about yourself and and how you even
end up in the theater
yeah so uh first of all there is some
background it's because we're in kobe
time so you'll see my girl you'll hear
my girls
screaming a little bit i'm sorry for
that i hope you will be able to take it
off
it's a perfect edition we're not gonna
remove every anything i promise you
okay so uh i started uh
uh you know when i went to a flight
academy it
was something quite opportunistic i
never had a dream to become a pilot
uh and i know i just ruled uh
i would say that uh when i started
flying
i really uh i really wasn't
uh you know a major fan i didn't fall in
love and at the first sight
um and it took some time but it uh you
know in the second year when we started
flying and started flying jets that that
became
um much more interesting and uh
you know the fact that you moved from 2d
to 3d was quite amazing
but then uh uh you know uh or you know
the most
uh i would say the first breaking point
in my career
was uh when uh the air force decided
that i'm not good enough to be a
fighter pilot i would become a cargo
pilot
and that killed me and i think that was
a very
important moment in my life
and it took me i would say four to five
years to overcome
that uh that point yeah
so just as a little background for those
who don't know i mean you know in israel
we grow up knowing we're going to go to
the air force i guess unlike your
journey
most people that go to the pilot school
are have this burning desire within them
from pretty much
birth to become pilots because you have
to undergo this intense
three-year pilot course right where it's
notoriously one of the most difficult
experiences
and that people go through i i think
it's incredibly impressive they didn't
even
didn't even plan on doing that but then
you know obviously
the people want to be fire pilots and so
i understand i understand what's going
on there but
why was it why was it such a turning
point for you that you even reflected
right now
so many years later because
you know when you're 19 you haven't
experienced you know
any or at least you know for me i didn't
experience the situation that i couldn't
get something that they really wanted
you know if you fail on a test and you
can do it again if you are
you know you want to uh uh you
as a teenager i wanted to to work
somewhere and i
failed to work you know at some specific
place and i went to another one
here this is the first time when this
decision is not reversible
they tell you okay you just don't have
the capabilities required to become a
fighter pilot
nothing that you can do will change that
and i looked in the history i looked for
you know other situations where cargo
par the pilots uh
were able to uh you know come back to
flight academy and become fighter pilots
there was only one specific case and you
know i didn't qualify to to those
specific criterias
so that was the point is that the is is
that what you
know did you reflect back on it because
you're in in some way you also said
saying
you know i'm thankful that that it
happened as
a as a meaningful turning point what do
you how do you see it
following your journey so
you know it it uh that was you know the
the first interaction uh
uh when the second interaction with uh
the uh
uh the fighter uh a dream was when my
uh squadron commander uh he offered me
to uh to join the experimental squadron
in the air force and i was like the only
cargo pilot over there and my job was to
uh mediate between the engineering and
the pilot and to help to better organize
and plan
uh experimental flights and then you
have like
the most the best fighter pilots in the
air force
doing the you know the edge cases
flights uh taking the
the jets to the you know the boundaries
and uh i was sitting in planning flight
at that point i said okay
i have to make a change so there were
two groups there were the fighter pilots
and they were the smart
engineers planning the fight i decided
okay i have to move to the second group
and at that point i decided i want to
become an engineer
yeah and uh two million
two months into my uh into my uh
my new position in experimental squadron
i just uh signed up
to biomedical engineering and started uh
my first degree in parallel to uh
serving in the pilot in the air force
incredible so you're
so you're going through this experience
in the in the air force you find
yourself in this experimental which
i i have to say sounds exhilarating uh
taking the taking that
to the edge and how do you then you know
finish your service
and a very meaningful service do you
know you want to be an entrepreneur or
do you want to go into the
first of all you know the the life
sciences with v and then
to become an investor
so what happened uh uh a few years after
that
i was like in uh the third year of the
university
was that there was a the horrible
accident of a saffroman
so assassin was a fighter pilot uh
he had a crash with an f-16
the reason was a g-loc g-loss of
conscience uh to those who are not
familiar with the family
uh his father ilan was uh the first
israeli astronaut
and he died in the colombia uh and uh
uh and when his son died in this uh f-16
accident
uh my partner and only off and me we
were like uh uh completely puzzled we
did not understand
how isn't there a sensor that can
identify when a product is about to say
it
and just connect to the autopilot and
allow the
pilot to grab himself together and take
the plane
back to landing so at that point uh
decide okay we have a mission we need to
figure this out
long story short we developed a solution
that allows to identify when those
pilots are about
to faint and together with elbit
we built a solution that allows to
connect
with a pilot and to allow the plane to
take control whenever is needed uh
when the sensor identified that
something is uh went really wrong
so is that really the beginning of the
this interaction between
you know a device and and our
consciousness or our
or our physical being and then having
you know
smart sensors or analytics based on that
is that really the the beginning point
of that
yeah that's definitely the beginning you
know it was well
we were like we were really kids we were
we had no uh business
vision intuition whatsoever
looking at this market this was a tiny
tiny tiny market
obviously we could not raise money from
vcs you know how many
western pilots are there in the world
not too much uh and uh
and so we were we got support uh for the
ministry of defense
uh and were able to develop this
solution uh
and at some point at some level of
maturity
we shook hands with elbit and l bit uh
took
this uh and you know developed it
to into a real product and we decided to
take the
technological assets that we had at the
point which was
the physics and the capability to to
develop optical sensors to monitor
physiological parameters
the signal processing capabilities that
allowed to extract
the most interesting physiological
signals out of the sensor
and translate all of that into very
simplified
actionable insights so for the fighter
jet it was
just you know green all good orange
uh be careful you're about to faint or
something wrong about to happen
red autopilot take control so all that
sophistication
is translated into three uh specific
scenarios
so we wanted to take the same the same
technological assets and product
perspective
into the welfare for the world
exactly and go into fitness wellness
and allow you know it you know when you
are
at the point we were like uh you know
you have a uh uh
you want to run a marathon and now both
of us are where we can do 5k in 30
minutes
but we if we will evolve differently you
know we are at a different age
we are at uh we have different dna we
eat differently we sleep differently
why isn't there uh a solution that can
monitor your physiology
and to customize the training
uh progress specifically to your needs
so if you can progress faster then the
the training uh plan will adapt to your
to your progress
right now that makes perfect sense i
have to say that i wish that i had used
this because i
i myself trained for a marathon i guess
it was about five years ago i
you know obviously i didn't really have
uh anything that
that i could sense about my body except
for my own mental being
and obviously as you're running the
marathon hey god forbid you're gonna
stop even if your legs are falling off
and so i did end up finished but but you
know there were repercussions and i
definitely wish
that i had things like this but what i'm
you know what i'm sensing here in this
in this journey is you know first of all
a lot of you know
things that the opportunities that came
about and harnessing them right so i
think that one of the things that i'm
that i'm seeing through this show is
that a lot of you know a lot of the
times i can go back and say yes of
course tabika
you know studied really hard to go to
the air force academy he became a pilot
he discovered that technology is you
know the way to go and then he
understood that he can then democratize
this for the real world and then he
became one of the top investors in
israel
and it all makes perfect sense but what
i'm hearing from you in hindsight is
that
a lot of these things are you know
harnessing the opportunity accepting it
by circumstance and and then leveraging
it to push it forward right
exactly you know i think that almost
everything is event driven
you need to find those points in life
where you create uh
boosts of motivation and to leverage
opportunities
right now i think that's a i think
that's amazing
today you're a general partner at one of
the most incredible venture capital
groups in israel viola ventures
and like i mentioned you're sitting on
the board of some of the most uh you
know
deep technology driven companies in
israel
uh tell me a little bit about you know
your entrance into the vc world and
specifically about viola
and and how you look at the investments
that you lead within the group
so uh i joined viola
more than four years ago the areas that
i cover are areas where
the major risk is in product development
uh while most of the companies usually
the major risk is and go to market in
scale
so the entrepreneurs that i meet
are presenting a problem which is a
well-defined
problem and if their solution works
then there will definitely be buyers uh
and i'll give you two examples
one is a company called uh protantix uh
protantix was founded by uh metallux
founders
and they identified a very important
trend
where uh mission critical systems
are dependent or becoming dependent on
electronics not on mechanics so if you
look at a car 10 years ago you had
five 10 chips today you have thousands
of chips
so most of the malfunctions
moving forward will become will come
from
issues with electronics but there wasn't
any solution that allowed the
semiconductor the chips to talk
so they came with a you know a
revolutionary
idea let's integrate agents into the
chips
and allow them to talk and when
something goes wrong
then they will be able to uh identify
the
the the root cause and provide a
solution
so so the idea was this is the very
sophisticated
uh deep tech solution it
meets you know a specific trend that
we're all experiencing and it was
you know quite obvious that if they
would be able
to develop this type of a solution then
you know
automotive oems would buy it uh cloud
providers would buy it uh
industrial manufacturing uh uh hardware
would buy it
the major challenge within the
technology and
uh and and you know another and that's
that's one example another great example
of the company that you mentioned before
is immunized
and nimby and i uh uh yeah so so
really lewis and norm are amazing
amazing entrepreneurs
and they came with an idea thing that uh
you know the immune immune system is a
black box
and it's time to to reprogram the immune
system and you know five years ago it
was not possible because you did not
have
the information the data that would
allow to hack
this uh this system but but now when you
have single cell rna
then you can extract much more
information and the
regularity of the data allows ai
to create manipulations and extract
insights
that really allow the hacking of the
immune system
so so these are two examples of deep
tech technologies
that at the point when we invested at
the seed stage it was
you know uh we still in pretentious was
the seed stage when we invested in
immunize was actually in the a round
but it was still siri there was not you
know a real product in place
but given the timing trends uh uh
uh introduction of new technologies uh
we believe that at that point if they
succeed
then they can really you know create a
dent and an impact
uh in a significant market i love it so
it's because thinking
taking up you know 30 000 feet and one
of the things that you mentioned that i
want to
dive deep on is this idea that you know
most startups i guess
you know more than 90 of startups really
their biggest challenge from day one is
this okay this go to market
do you have product market fit like are
people actually going to enjoy using
this product
but then there is this you know the
small margin of
of startups that are leveraging deep
technology and like you're mentioning
there
the risk while there might be some still
risk about their go to market and
whether
you know they have oems and whether they
can people can still uh they can still
sell but
the bigger question is can they actually
produce the technology
and it sounds to me that as an investor
you have to be in a very different
mindset when you invest in those types
of companies
rather than rather than more traditional
startups that than one won't see in
their day-to-day so
how do you see you know your perhaps due
diligence approach or your thinking
approach differ
from that of an investor who's
concentrating more in
not necessarily deep tech but more
companies whose risk
management is the go to market and
product market
so so i think it really uh depends on
the specific vertical
so uh you know if you look at
semiconductors i think that
investing in and you know and first time
semiconductor entrepreneurs it's much
more challenging
when we look at semiconductors there is
so much knowledge and expertise that you
need to have
so uh when we invest in a semiconductor
entrepreneur we do
you know a lot of it is based on past
achievements
um and to understand you know
uh if all the the great stuff that this
these
individuals in the past are they only
you know
are or they are one trick pony or can
they really expand
and look into near new areas so i'm
trying to understand how curious these
guys are
what type of background research did
they do how did they enrich the team
uh uh so so that's for for stomach
turtle when you look at
you know new brave world like uh
computational biologist
then there is not enough legacy to find
those people that did already ten times
in the past
so you're looking for first of all
people have to be super bright
how do you evaluate intelligence just
spending more and more time with these
people
uh when you look at uh the more
complicated problems
then you're looking at more uh you know
rounded holistic themes so if you look
at computational biology you need
immunologists you need computational
biologists you need uh
uh mathematicians and and when i
look at these types of teams i try to uh
first
you know understand what is the baseline
uh of the founders and what type of
people are they able to recruit
because these are teams to win they have
recruit the best of the best
so the best indication is to see were
they able to bring
uh top-notch people into different in
different disciplines
and if they were this mean that these
you know those top-notch people
were uh appreciated enough or they were
interested and we're curious enough to
follow
these people and that's a very good
indication to see if uh if this team can
break you know those uh
very uh uh complicated uh tests
now do you go ahead and assume that you
know any
problem that is meaningful enough to
solve that takes enough you know
brains and manpower to solve is relevant
for the world because one of the things
that i'm that i'm observing and as i
walk you know
in in the in the floor minus three of
the engineering building at stanford i
see a lot of
you know fascinating phd thesis you know
people working for
you know ten years on on different ai
models or trying to prove
the plausibility of something happening
i don't see
all of them you know being able to reach
a product stage even if the research
does turn out
to be you know to be effective so how do
you
you do have to go and still evaluate
whether there is some market for this
right it's not just
okay if you if you work on a problem
that is meaningful enough for 10 years
and you solve it then automatically your
is you're going to be successful
right so you know in deep tech companies
one of the challenges is that you need
to
try to predict will there be a need for
this type of a solution in four years or
five years from now right
it's not like your development sales
product did so so here
this this diligence requires you know
hours of conversations of people coming
from the domain
and yeah and understanding how do they
see trend in the market
uh right what uh and so so it's really
important to not
you know uh to speak with people that
have enough intuition
and and depth to hear what do they see
what will happen the market is three to
four to five years from now
and when we invest in those companies
you know the existing market is zero
and we need to bet that in in five to
eight years from now this will be a
multi billion dollar market so
uh that i think would be the most
significant challenge
i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time and for coming
to speak with me i know how busy you are
and i i love you know the world of deep
technology and
and i think that you know looking at the
market that doesn't necessarily exist
and working on a problem that
you know will be hopefully solvable in
four or five years and
and then trying to understand trying to
align whether the market will be there
or it won't be there i think that's
one of the most exciting things possible
and obviously looking at the companies
that you're on the board of and have
invested with
it's part of the alliance and it's
remarkable and i think that these some
of these companies are literally
going to change the world if not today
then in three four years and but thank
you for being here and the most
important question i have for you
is three words that you would choose to
describe yourself
okay uh i would say the first
one is i'm i'm quite stubborn
uh the second is uh
uh curious curiosity
and the third that i'm uh i'm quite
sensitive
interesting interesting combination of
those three
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you for having me good luck thanks
a lot
you